التسلح بالامن الغذائي قبل وقوع اي ازمه
سياسيه او اقتصاديه تمتد تداعياتها على
مستوى العالم امر التفت له الاردن مبكرا
البدايه كانت مع ازمه كورونا وتاثيرها على
الامن الغذائي العالمي ومع تداعيات الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه واجه الاردن للازمه
باعتماده على مخزون سلع غذائيه وقمح وشعير
تم استيرادها مسبقا بكميات رفضت ما يعرف
بالمخزون الاحتياطي تم رفع الساعات
التخزينيه في المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
سواء من خلال انشاء صوامع الصوامع
العموديه او من خلال الصور مع الافقيه
يعني في عنا مخطط حاليا انه نرفع الساعات
التخزينيه الى مليونين وربع طن يستورد من
مادتين القمح والشعير مليون طن لكل ماده
بمعنى انه اثنين مليون طن سنويا بنستورد
شعير ومنستورد قمح بشكل عام
وكذلك واحده من الايجابيات يرحلوا انه
صحيح البحر الاسود لكن في اخر خمس سنوات
لم يتم استيراد من اوكرانيا نهائيا
الحكومه الاردنيه تحملت تكاليف ارتفاع
القمح والشعير كمادتين اساسيتين من
الخزينه العامه للدوله في ظل الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه دون اي ارتفاع على
المستهلك بسبب دعمها لمادتي الخبز والشعير
فيما تاثرت اسعار السلع الاخرى المستورده
من قبل القطاع الخاص بارتفاع ملموس عاد
للاستقرار من جديد بعد مرور عام على الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه ما في اي مواطن راح
على اي سوبر ماركت وكان في يواجه نقص باي
سلعه تموينيه بقيت سلاسل التوريد مستمره
وما حصل عنا اي نقص سواء في جائحه كورونا
او في الازمنه الاوكرانيه فيما يبقى
التحدي الاصعب في امكانيه تحقيق امن غذائي
مستقبلي في ظل تغيرات مناخيه وفقر مائي
يعد اساسا لانتاج المواد الزراعيه في بلد
يعتمد على استيراد معظم احتياجاته عماد
الى العربيه عمان